ddt is an abbreviation of the name
and there's quite a nice little poem
which my daughter learned to say when
she was only three
and i quite like so i'll tell it to you
now
it goes a mosquito was heard to complain
that chemists had poisoned his brain the
cause of his sorrow
was paradichloro diphenyl
trichloroethane
hence d d and t
an insecticide is something that kills
insects
doesn't discourage them they still come
to you
but if they get it on them in particular
i think in with
ddt on their feet they die so you can
see it's labeled as being toxic
so let's open it and
here we've got 11.2 grams ddt
was developed in the early stages of the
second world war
to stop the troops from getting lice
the small insects that from as long as
anyone can remember and
hundreds of years before then have lived
in the clothes of soldiers
who are fighting and don't have time to
wash or change their clothes
during the second world war when the
allies
invaded italy and liberated naples
a huge epidemic started because of lies
among all the children
and the refugees and
there's a terrific picture here in this
old book
showing child being treated and his
mother
being treated with ddt but now
ddt has quite a bad reputation and the
bad reputation
started with his book by an american
author
rachel carson it's called
silent spring in the spring the birds
sing
and her point was that in the nine early
1960s
in much of the midwest of america
there weren't any bird singing or far
fewer than normal
and the reason and some people argue
about some of the numbers and things in
this book but the reason she put forward
was that insecticides like ddt
were being used in huge amounts the
birds were eating the insects
that had absorbed some of this ddt
and because they were eating so much
they accumulated ddt in their bodies
and the ddt damaged the production of
eggshells
so that when they laid their eggs the
shells were soft
and the birds didn't hatch properly now
the problem is
that ddt because when it's concentrated
in this way
is harmful to wildlife but
when it's used in human
environment it's used in lower
concentrations
we don't eat the ddt so it's not really
bad for humans but it's fantastically
good
for killing insects like mosquitoes
mosquitoes spread malaria
huge numbers of children even now die
each year through malaria
so there is a very difficult problem to
which nobody
knows the answer not me i don't think
you either
which is how do you balance
the benefits to human people killing the
insects
so that young children don't die of
malaria
on one hand and on the other hand
preserving
wildlife and preventing ddt accumulating
in the environment
and you can see like most
organic chemicals it's just a white
crystalline powder
this is the official name 1 1 base 4
chloro phenyl 2 2 2 trichloro
ethane used by the international union
of pure and applied chemistry
the initial ddt came because when it was
invented in the 1940s or
late 1930s it really was the
abbreviation from the name
now that we have changed the name so we
have base rather than die
for meaning two i suppose
if it had been invented now it would be
called bdt
i have no idea how it kills them though
i've been told
that if you take the deuterated compound
where the one hydrogen atom has
deuterium
instead doesn't kill the insects because
they can get rid of it
out of their body faster than the carbon
deuterium bond breaks
but i don't know whether this is true or
not it sounds plausible